[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas a lo largo de las semanas
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
nuestro último programa del 2021 a
continuación algunos de los temas que
trataremos os
vamos a hablar de ese aumento en las
cifras de fallecidos de los
profesionales de la salud a nivel global
también veremos como la tasa de
natalidad ha disminuido en todo el
planeta debido a la pandemia de kobe 19
los detalles se los tengo en unos
minutos también en este programa de hoy
daremos una mirada a la situación
epidemiológica en países como brasil
chile bolivia y costa rica veremos cómo
está avanzando la vacunación y cuáles
fueron las noticias y los anuncios más
destacados a lo largo de esta semana en
torno a la pandemia en estos países y en
nuestra habitual consulta con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez epidemiólogo y
también asesor científico de france 24
hablaremos sobre los últimos hallazgos
sobre el origen del cob y 19 también el
desarrollo de una vacuna de origen
vegetal y la dosis de refuerzo o tercera
dosis que sigue causando controversia en
algunos países vamos a comenzar el
programa y lo hacemos con las cifras y
lo hacemos viendo el panorama de cómo
avanza la pandemia de kobe 19 en esta
oportunidad por ser nuestro último
programa del año les presento las cifras
globales así está el planeta frente a la
pandemia de kobe 19 casos totales desde
el inicio de la emergencia más de 268
millones 800 mil casos personas que
lamentablemente han fallecido más de 52
millones dosis de la vacuna administrada
a nivel global más de 8 mil 367 millones
147 mil dosis alrededor de todo el mundo
el 45 24 por ciento de la población
mundial tiene vacunación completa contra
el cob y 19
ya lo hemos dicho los profesionales de
la salud han sido los verdaderos héroes
de esta emergencia sanitaria global que
continúa cerca de 5,2 millones de
personas que trabajan en el sector de la
salud han perdido su vida en la lucha
por garantizar la vida de otros es sólo
uno de los efectos que ha tenido la
pandemia de kobe 19 también la tasa de
natalidad mundial ha disminuido
considerablemente veamos
la pandemia de kobe 19 se cobró hasta
ahora más de 529 millones de vidas pero
de esta cifra cuántos eran profesionales
de la salud entre 80 mil y 180 mil
profesionales sanitarios y asistenciales
podrían haber muerto a causa del hobbit
19 en el período comprendido entre enero
de 2020 y mayo de 2021 esto significa
que de media 115 mil 500 trabajadores
perdieron la vida durante la pandemia
según cálculos de la organización
mundial de la salud según la
organización panamericana de la salud
más de 10.000 de esas defunciones
tuvieron lugar en américa latina donde
el personal de salud también hace frente
al agotamiento estrés ansiedad y fatiga
pero el impacto de la pandemia de kobe
19 no solo se mide por el número de
muertes la crisis sanitaria también ha
provocado un descenso de la natalidad
especialmente en los países
desarrollados según los investigadores
de las razones principales sería el
miedo a un futuro incierto y las
repercusiones económicas de la crisis un
estudio internacional liderado por la
universidad de bocconi en italia llevado
a cabo en 22 países de renta alta lo
demostró las tasas brutas de natalidad
descendieron un 9.1 por ciento en italia
un 8.5 por ciento en hungría un 8.4 por
ciento en españa y un 6.6 por ciento en
portugal además bélgica austria y
singapur también mostraron un descenso
significativo por otro lado un estudio
realizado por las universidades de viena
en austria y max planck en alemania
advirtió que en américa latina' 12
millones de mujeres no tuvieron acceso a
métodos anticonceptivos por lo que se
calcula que el número de embarazos no
deseados asciende a 1,4 millones como
consecuencia de la crisis sanitaria en
esta región
después de varios estudios las
farmacéuticas pfizer y variante que
indicaron que una tercera dosis de su
vacuna contra el kobe 19 podría proteger
contra la variante omicron este anuncio
tiene lugar después de que la oms se
hiciera también un llamado mundial a
revisar la forma en que los países han
dado respuesta precisamente a la
aparición de la variante omicron veamos
las vacunas de refuerzo podrían ser
clave contra la variante omicron según
resultados preliminares de las empresas
vayan tec y facer robert three stories
los estudios de laboratorio muestran que
tres dosis de nuestra vacuna neutralizan
la variante omicron mientras que dos
dosis reducen significativamente la
neutralización de esta nueva variante
youzhny otro live nation of first new
berlin by ante kim fases son los
primeros fabricantes de una vacuna
contra el kobe 19 que emiten una
actualización oficial sobre la eficacia
de su vacuna contra el micro
hoy es un mensaje positivo que creemos
que debería calmar y reconfortar a todo
el mundo para que no se preocupe sino
que por favor vaya y se vacune 3 dosis
es realmente lo que se requiere para
protegerse eficazmente de omikron
lippert tec como metro la organización
mundial de la salud clasificó el 26 de
noviembre a un micrón como una variante
preocupante y este miércoles pidió a los
gobiernos que revisen de manera urgente
sus estrategias para contenerla
las restricciones que impiden los
contagios van a ser eficaces económica o
con cualquier otra variante pero esto no
únicamente pasa por la vacuna sino por
las medidas de protección de la
mascarilla la distancia física de la
higiene y las medidas restrictivas que
impiden las interacciones sociales
despótica todavía no hay datos
significativos sobre como las vacunas de
modernas johnson y johnson y otros
fabricantes se enfrentan a la nueva
variante pero se espera que publiquen
sus propios datos en las próximas
semanas
vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez él es médico infectólogo
asesor científico de france 24 ya está
con nosotros para nuestra habitual
consulta la última del año 2021 de
doctor pérez como siempre un gusto
tenerlo con nosotros en el programa y
comienzo preguntándole por las novedades
que hay en cuanto a la investigación
sobre el origen del sars kof 2 si bien
ya está completamente descartado que
esté coronavirus no fue diseñado como un
arma biológica nuevos hallazgos dicen
que podría estar relacionado con eso no
sé de qué se trata esto
recordemos que son gnosis quiere decir
aquellas todas las infecciones que son
transmitidas de los animales a los
hombres lo que se ha documentado es que
probablemente el origen si sea en el
mundo en el reino animal y se haya
pasado a los humanos digámoslo así es la
infección esto es muy importante
establecerlo porque nos permitirá la
vigilancia sobre cierto grupo animales
sobre cierto el grupo de animales
silvestres para poder prevenir un nuevo
brote este tipo de virus
teoría que sigue cobrando fuerza a nivel
de el planeta a nivel científico de
doctor pérez hablemos ahora de la
organización mundial de la salud que
informó que después de una revisión de
algunos datos en algunas vacunas estaría
mejor poner dosis de refuerzo seis meses
después de la última dosis que ha
recibido cada uno de los pacientes pero
esto contrasta precisamente con lo que
dijo la farmacéutica pfiezer variante
que ellos recomiendan que sea cada tres
meses por lo menos su vacuna la de la
farmacéutica falsa
recordemos que la inmunidad se precisa
es con los niveles de anticuerpos y otro
que se llama la inmunidad celular lo que
el alma s establece es que para
cualquier vacuna que ellos han aprobado
seis meses de esa protección lo que
relata la casa farmacéutica que fabrica
la vacuna de facer variante que es que
este del tercer mes muestra un
decrecimiento en la cantidad de
anticuerpos no necesariamente significa
que haya refuerzo en toda la población
pero si llama la atención de que podrá
blemente se tengan que medir esos
anticuerpos para poder hacer un refuerzo
36 meses o 9 meses después todavía
tenemos claro que el intervalo de
aplicación de la vacuna es al menos seis
meses después de la segunda dosis pero
todas nos falta un trecho para saber si
en poblaciones especiales o muy muy
sutiles trasplantados retiramos que esos
intervalos sean más cortos entonces esto
este ir dilucidando qué va a pasar en el
futuro próximo sobre todo cuantificando
la inmunidad celular que también es
importante
doctor hablemos ahora de novedades que
hay en torno al desarrollo de vacunas y
es que en argentina comprobaron la
eficacia de una vacuna de origen vegetal
es una vacuna que está siendo
desarrollada por una farmacéutica
canadiense que está haciendo sus
estudios allí en argentina que se
comenta en la comunidad científica en
torno a esta vacuna y que quiere decir
que sea una vacuna de origen vegetal
como como se produce
no digamos que esta información nos
falta precisar la mucho más a nivel
técnico y científico para hablar cuáles
son los componentes
recordemos que las vacunas son
estructuras químicas que lo que hacen es
que generar una respuesta inmunológica
tienen origen químico y tienen origen en
la manipulación que se puede hacer de
los agentes infecciosos en el momento
nosotros tenemos que ser cautos con este
tipo de informaciones evaluar primero
técnicamente de qué se trata y comprobar
los estudios clínicos sobre eléctricas y
la eficiencia esto se demoró un tiempo
para poder determinar en este momento
santiago es preciso decir que tenemos
que confiar en las vacunas que tenemos
disponibles hay muchos nuevos
desarrollos de nuevas vacunas de varias
casas para más cercas que tendremos en
el próximo año y por ahora tengamos la
información el uso de buen recaudo hasta
que tengamos con información más precisa
acerca de la efectividad de este tipo de
vacuna
doctor y para el cierre de esta consulta
le pregunto por una publicación de una
revista científica una revista
especializada que hablaba de un estudio
que está en desarrollo que ya incluso a
reclutar reclutado a unas 500 personas
que podrían ser resistentes al cob y 19
por factores genéticos es esto posible
hay información científica y médica que
demuestra que algunas personas son
genéticamente
imposible de contagiarse algún tipo de
enfermedad si en esto de ccoo estamos
aprendiendo con el pasar del tiempo y lo
que se ha visto es que hay personas que
han sido expuestas por ejemplo en grupos
familiares a la misma cantidad de virus
oa la presencia del virus
algunas enfermas mientras no enfermaron
se ha seleccionado es el grupo de
personas elector en grupos familiares o
de reuniones donde se documentó que si
había la exposición y que las personas
no desarrollaron coronarios para saber
qué características genética tienen y
eso va a ser muy importante para
desarrollar nuevos fármacos
medicamentos vacunas porque podríamos
precisar
a que se hace resistente al virus del
sistema tecnológico estamos muy
pendientes eso sucede también por
ejemplo santiago de personas en vih una
de cada 400 personas pueden cuadrar los
transporte en la resistencia natural al
vih y en varias enfermedades infecciosas
se ha podido documentar eso como también
hay características genéticas que lo
hacen más potencia en primarias
infecciosas falta de un tiempo para
evaluar esto pero es una muy interesante
pregunta que esperamos una apuesta para
tener mejores desarrollos de nuestros
fármacos doctor muy interesante este
tema de la resistencia que pueden tener
algunas personas al cob y 19 muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado en este
programa y a lo largo de todo este año
para resolver todas las dudas y
preguntas de nuestros televidentes y de
nuestros compañeros en la redacción
doctor y nos vemos en el 2022 por
supuesto aquí en el programa feliz
navidad y feliz año desde ya veamos
entonces ahora cómo avanza la vacunación
en el continente americano les
presentamos a continuación las cifras
correspondientes a dosis administradas
por cada 100.000 habitantes miren la
lista a nivel mundial la encabeza un
país latinoamericano cuba con 253 mil
setecientos cincuenta y una dosis por
cada 100.000 habitantes en cuarto lugar
a nivel mundial está chile con 219 mil
604 dosis por cada 100.000 habitantes
uruguay está en la sexta posición a
nivel mundial con un poco más de 197.000
dosis por cada 100.000 habitantes de ahí
saltamos hasta la décimo segunda
posición o puesto o décimo cuarta
posición puesto número 24 para canadá
con más de 166 mil 121 dosis y de ahí
saltamos hasta la posición número 40 en
donde se encuentra argentina con más de
150 mil 600 dosis por cada 100.000
habitantes
hablamos ahora de méxico este país tiene
un promedio de 17 por ciento de
ocupación de las camas generales en la
red hospitalaria la ocupación de las
camas de las unidades de cuidado
intensivo llega al 13 por ciento pero la
aparición de varios casos de la variante
omicron alertó a las autoridades y llevó
a impulsar la vacunación de refuerzo
para las personas mayores de 60 años el
reportaje de ariana villacorta para kobe
19 la semana en américa
el gobierno de méxico tomó una decisión
tras meses de estar descartando la luego
de que el pasado fin de semana se
detectara el primer caso de la variante
omicron del cob y 19 en el país azteca
el cambio de la política de vacunación
es para incluir refuerzo refuerzo de las
vacunas a las personas adultas mayores
60 años y más
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador ya recibió la dosis de
refuerzo sin embargo las autoridades no
prevén de momento incluir en esta
campaña al resto de la población según
la secretaria de salud de este país
desde finales de diciembre de 2020 han
llegado a méxico poco más de 185
millones de dosis de vacunas de facer
johnson y johnson modernas astrazéneca
sputnik cancino y si novak que han
servido para inocular a 78 millones de
adultos en la nación latinoamericana que
cuenta con más de 126 millones de
habitantes esto representa el 86 por
ciento de la población mayor de edad de
ese porcentaje el 83 por ciento
inmunizada con el esquema completo que
ya hace tiempo existe unos meses me
pusieron a las otras dos y hoy vienen
por mí el esfuerzo porque este quiero
seguirme protegiendo pero lo ha visto
uno vio un objetivo no de tantas
personas vecinos que fueron renuentes a
su hogar a su vacunación y pacas del el
estado
no pues creo que sí vale la pena y aquí
estamos aún así méxico se mantiene como
el 15º país en número de contagios y
como el cuarto con más muertes por kobe
19 según el recuento de la universidad
johns hopkins
nos vamos ahora hasta centroamérica para
conocer las novedades destacadas de esta
semana en costa rica allí en san jose en
la capital está cindy regidor
corresponsal de france 24
hola cindy gracias por acompañarnos en
el programa y adelante con su reporte
por primera vez en 17 meses costa rica-
no registró muertes por coronavirus el
país contabiliza más de 7000 muertes
desde que empezó la emergencia sanitaria
esta baja en fallecimientos también en
hospitalizaciones y casos positivos
empezó en octubre lo que permitió que el
sistema de salud volviera un poco a la
normalidad en sus servicios de esta
manera parece que llega a su fin una
larga ola pandémica gracias a ello el
gobierno además flexibilizó las medidas
restrictivas relacionadas a movilidad y
aglomeraciones incluyendo actividades
masivas como juegos deportivos
conciertos y clases eso sí el gobierno
insta a que los establecimientos pidan
certificado de vacunación a los
asistentes el turismo una de las
principales actividades económicas del
país también se ha venido recuperando en
los últimos meses con la reanudación de
varios vuelos directos desde grandes
ciudades del mundo estas buenas noticias
se deben en gran medida a la vacunación
contra la cob y 19 hasta esta semana más
del 63 por ciento de la población ya
había recibido las dos dosis de la
vacuna y a partir de la próxima semana
las personas de 65 años y más
y una dosis de refuerzo los
especialistas prevén que los bajos
números de contagios y muertes se
mantengan así en las próximas semanas
pero llaman a la población a que no se
descuiden y sigan aplicando las medidas
como el uso de mascarilla y lavado de
manos sobre todo con la inminente
aparición de la variante omicron que ya
fue detectada en el continente y es de
preocupación para la organización
mundial de la salud los científicos y la
comunidad médica siguen investigando
cuáles son las particularidades de la
variante omicron de kobe 19 que fue dada
a conocer por un grupo de epidemiólogos
en sudáfrica desde donde dieron una
alerta mundial las investigaciones
siguen avanzando y hasta ahora esta
variante está presente en al menos 40
países omicron tiene como
particularidades múltiples mutaciones
pero hay algo más que han hallado los
científicos veamos reportada por primera
vez ante la organización mundial de la
salud el 24 de noviembre la variante o
micro amd del cobi 19 ha alcanzado al
menos 40 países la mitad de ellos
europeos pero que sabemos el nuevo
linaje del coronavirus en primer lugar
que omicron tiene muchas más mutaciones
que la variante delta en esta imagen
creada por investigadores italianos
vemos a omicron con 50 mutaciones al
menos 30 de ellas en la proteína de pico
la parte que se une a las células
humanas los expertos afirman que es
probable que la nueva variante se
propague más rápidamente que otras pero
esto aún está sujeto a análisis también
habrá que investigar para determinar si
o micro en causa enfermedades más graves
está claro que esta variante es mucho
más contagiosa que la variante delta no
hay ninguna información clínica que nos
diga qué omicron es más peligrosa para
los humanos que la variante delta lo
cual es tranquilizador por el momento
todavía se desconoce si las vacunas
actuales contra el kobe 19 son eficaces
contra la última variante pero varias
farmacéuticas ya han empezado a trabajar
en nuevas versiones de sus vacunas para
atacar mejor a om y chrome a pesar de la
atención que ha suscitado deltas sigue
siendo la variante dominante o mi hijo
mi papá o mi crono debe cambiar nuestras
prioridades actuales las prioridades
actuales son superar el pico de la
quinta ola y comenzar el declive para
luego reducir la circulación lo máximo
posible y llegar a la tasa más baja para
enero febrero y marzo y una cosa
independientemente de las incógnitas los
centros de control de enfermedades de
eeuu dicen que tenemos las herramientas
necesarias para luchar contra un micro y
enfatizan que las vacunas el uso de
mascarillas y las pruebas periódicas son
las mejores formas de protección
bueno las investigaciones continúan en
torno a esta nueva variante la siguiente
parada en nuestra ronda de
corresponsables nos lleva hasta el sur
del continente hasta chile patricia luna
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de santiago nos cuenta las novedades
destacadas de esta semana en ese país
austral y también los detalles de la
situación epidemiológica hola patricia
gracias por acompañarnos y cuáles fueron
los hechos destacados de esta semana y
en chile'
si no se sitúa esta semana como líder
mundial en la aplicación de dosis de
refuerzo de las que ya se han
administrado más de 9 millones de dosis
en el país mientras avanza la vacunación
de los 15,2 millones de chilenos que
constituyen la población objetiva frente
a los 19 millones de chilenos que
existen más de un 93% ya se ha vacunado
completamente en el país también se
sitúa a la cabeza esta semana al iniciar
la vacunación en niños de 3 a 6 años en
total 700.000 niños podrán recibir a
partir de ahora en la vacuna china
sinovac y recordemos que chile lleva ya
varios meses vacunando a personas
menores de 18 años el porcentaje de
personas vacunadas de los 18 a los 3
años completamente es de un 63% las
cifras siguen siendo bajas en el país en
las últimas 24 horas se registraban
1.500 casos positivos además una
positividad del 2,67 por ciento a nivel
nacional y de un 1 por ciento en la
región metropolitana son estas bajas
cifras la que permiten a toda la región
metropolitana avanzar esta semana en el
plan paso a paso del gobierno a la fase
de apertura inicial que permitirá
mayores especialmente para las personas
vacunadas o con pases de movilidad por
ejemplo hasta 50 personas podrán
reunirse en un domicilio particular si
todas ellas están vacunadas además en el
país ya ha llegado la variante o micro
se registran 5 casos todos los contactos
estrechos de la persona inicial que
porta el virus en el país en total desde
el inicio de la pandemia un millón 800
mil personas aproximadamente un poco
menos se han contagiado de coronavirus y
aproximadamente un poco menos de 40 mil
han fallecido por esta enfermedad
ya lo decíamos chiles se mantiene como
un líder indiscutible de la vacunación
no solamente en la región de américa
latina sino también a nivel mundial
cerca del 85% de sus casi 19 millones de
habitantes ya han recibido la vacunación
completa en el siguiente informe
profundizamos en la situación de
vacunación allí en chile
cerca de 700.000 niños y niñas de entre
3 y 5 años ya pueden vacunarse contra el
kobe 19 en chile siempre y cuando tengan
la autorización de sus padres los
primeros días se dio preferencia a los
menores con comorbilidades pero ahora
todos son elegibles el proceso de
vacunación se realiza en los cesfam y
vacunatorios a lo largo de todo el país
todo esto gracias a que un alto
porcentaje de la población chilena ya ha
sido inoculado con el esquema completo
al día de hoy ya tenemos más de 16
millones de chilenas y chilenos
vacunados con sus dos dosis es decir
cerca del 90% de la población más del 76
por ciento de los niños y jóvenes entre
6 y 17 años ya han recibido sus 2 dosis
y casi 9 millones de personas ya han
recibido su tercera dosis de refuerzo
con esto chile se ubica en el primer
lugar a nivel mundial en
porcentaje de su población con la vacuna
de refuerzo aún así las autoridades
sanitarias insisten en que se mantengan
las medidas
el uso correcto de la mascarilla lavarse
las manos tomar distanciamiento físico y
ventilar frecuentemente los espacios
cerrados que junto a la vacuna han
logrado mejorar la situación sanitaria
en el país
se ha mantenido una tendencia a la baja
en la media móvil de casos nuevos y
esperamos que se siga consolidando
también han disminuido los ingresos
diarios a bussi por kobe 19 según un
estudio realizado por la organización a
rowling deira en los últimos días el
país sudamericano ha registrado menos de
10 muertes diarias en comparación a las
más de 220 que registraba en su punto
más crítico de la pandemia así las cosas
si les superan las 38 mil muertes entre
los más de 178 millones de contagios
y de chilenos vamos hasta bolivia para
conocer las noticias y los hechos
destacados relacionados con la pandemia
kobe 19 en ese país conectamos con mery
vaca en la ciudad de la paz hola mary
resumen entonces de lo más relevante
bolivia a lo largo de esta semana
adelante
bolivia está cursando la cuarta ola de
coronavirus con más de 1000 casos
diarios y el foco puesto principalmente
en la ciudad oriental de santa cruz
aunque la situación está todavía
controlada lo que se ha estancado es el
proceso de vacunación a las personas
mayores de 18 años sucede que en el país
mucha gente se niega a concurrir a los
centros de vacunación ya sea por
creencias o por desinformación tal es
así que informes oficiales indican que
sólo el 60 por ciento de la población
vacuna bleu mayor de 18 años ha
completado su esquema de inmunización
precisamente por ese motivo es que el
gobierno de luisa se ha decidido a abrir
la vacunación para menores de edad en
una primera instancia para adolescentes
comprendidos entre los 12 y los 18 años
y finalmente ha tomado la decisión de
que los niños comprendidos entre los 5 y
los 12 años también concurran a los
centros de vacunación para inmunizarse
de esta manera el gobierno pretende
garantizar la educación presencial a
partir del próximo año luego de
gestiones de déficit educativo en la
modalidad presencial pero también en la
modalidad virtual la vacuna que se está
colocando a los niños es la scinopharm
gracias a una donación del gobierno
chino de 3 millones de dosis para
bolivia
gracias mary mary vaca desde la paz
brasil argentina perú chile méxico y
ahora cuba son los países que ya
confirmaron casos de la variante o micro
la imposición de varias medidas y
restricciones por parte de los países de
la región ha sido la respuesta para
evitar su expansión así como fomentar la
vacunación
argentina se unió a brasil méjico perú y
chile en la lista de países
latinoamericanos donde se detectaron
casos de la nueva variante del
coronavirus omicron tras este primer
caso en una persona que había viajado
desde sudáfrica el gobierno pidió a los
argentinos que se mantuvieran en alerta
a la verdad que me preocupa mucho porque
bueno de nada ya vivimos el tema de este
del hobbit que estar encerrados y todo y
la verdad que es
nada se complica un montón toda esta
situación pero bueno esperemos que no
sea como la que bueno el primer país de
la región en anunciar un caso con esta
pariente fue brasil el alcalde de río de
janeiro tomó rápidamente medidas en
contra de las celebraciones de
nochevieja la fiesta de fin de año en el
estado del río de janeiro está
lamentablemente cancelada en mexico que
también ya presenta casos de omicron el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
anunció que este martes comenzará la
aplicación de dosis de refuerzo de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 entre los
adultos mayores en perú ante su primer
contagiado el gobierno anunció que el
carnet de vacunación será obligatorio
para los mayores de 18 años que ingresen
a espacios cerrados como restaurantes y
comercios otro país que tomó medidas
para controlar el ingreso de la nueva
variante y fue ecuador he dispuesto que
se aplique la siguiente medida
prohibición de entrada al territorio
nacional a toda persona cuyo punto de
origen
el tránsito sea la lista específica de
países del áfrica que serán publicados
por las autoridades competentes paraguay
tomó medidas similares mientras que
argentina decidió únicamente ordenar una
cuarentena a las personas que vengan de
algún país de áfrica y en brásil también
nuevo temas destacados a lo largo de
esta semana el gobierno rechazó el uso
de un pasaporte sanitario como medida de
control de la pandemia además el
incremento de casos de gripa ha
despertado el interés de las autoridades
ante el temor de un pico durante el
verano para conocer más detalles vamos
hasta río de janeiro allí se encuentra
valeria saccone valeria comencemos por
ese rechazo por parte del gobierno
brasileño del gobierno federal en cuanto
a la propuesta de usar un pasaporte
sanitario
esta semana el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro ha rechazado exigir a los
turistas que lleguen a brasil el
pasaporte de vacunación el ministro de
salud marcelo quiroga ha dicho
literalmente que es mejor perder la vida
que perder la libertad el gobierno de
brasil ha optado por pedir a los
turistas no vacunados que hagan una
cuarentena voluntaria de cinco días pero
ha habido muchas críticas porque no hay
forma de fiscalizar a los millares de
turistas que llegan para disfrutar del
verano tropical que está a punto de
empezar el temor es que brasil se
convierta en un destino para los
negacionistas para las personas que no
quieran tomar la vacuna además hoy ha
habido un ataque de 'hackers' contra el
sistema informático del ministerio de
salud y el pasaporte de vacuna de los
brasileños ha salido del aire por esa
razón el gobierno ha decidido que solo
va a exigir la a-40 de los turistas a
partir del 18 de diciembre
valeria veíamos en el informe lo de la
cancelación de las fiestas de fin de año
en la ciudad de río de janeiro que dicen
entonces ayer las autoridades y como han
tomado esto los cariocas
de momento el 65% de las grandes
ciudades de brasil ha cancelado total o
parcialmente los festejos de nochevieja
ante el avance de la o micro la variante
nueva y el coronavirus mirando sobre
todo lo que está pasando en europa y
esto a pesar de que el 65% de la
población de brasil está totalmente
vacunada entre esas ciudades está
sanpaolo la ciudad más grande de brasil
el caso de río de janeiro es diferente
los fuegos artificiales de la playa de
copacabana son famosos en todo el mundo
inicialmente fueron cancelados pero
después el ayuntamiento de río dio
marcha atrás y ha decidido a mantenerlos
en 10 puntos de la ciudad pero sin los
tradicionales espectáculos musicales
además ha habido una decisión muy
polémica no habrá refuerzo de transporte
público solamente se puede acceder a
copacabana hasta las 7 de la tarde y
muchas personas en el río dicen que es
una medida clasista porque deja a las
personas con menos poder adquisitivo
lejos de la playa y lejos de los famosos
fuegos artificiales además las fiestas
privadas también está permitidas y de
nuevo las críticas dicen sólo podrá
divertirse quien tenga dinero para
comprar la entrada
valeria también ha despertado interés
por parte de las autoridades sanitarias
de brasil un aumento en torno a los
casos de gripe y temen que haya un
repunte para mediados del verano que
dicen allí
cuando perfil pensaba que por fin estaba
controlando la pandemia de coronavirus
en su territorio llega otra emergencia
sanitaria la ciudad de río de janeiro
acaba de declarar una epidemia de gripe
común en la última semana los casos de
gripe superando en ocho veces los casos
de covite a finales de noviembre el
alcalde de río de janeiro eduardo paes
convocó a los cariocas a tomar
masivamente la vacuna contra la gripe
porque muchos habían dejado de hacerlo
por causa de la otra vacuna la vacuna
contra el coronavirus los cariocas
respondieron masivamente acudieron a los
centros de salud se acabaron las dosis y
tuvieron que parar el proceso de
vacunación el resultado de hospitales y
centros de salud abarrotados ahora esta
semana llegan nuevas dosis 560.000 desde
brasilia y desde el instituto butantán
de sao paulo pero estas dosis sólo van a
servir para cubrir la vacunación de una
semana y las autoridades sanitarias
están preocupadas de que esta epidemia
localiza de río de janeiro se pueda
a nivel nacional
muchas gracias valeria por este reporte
desde la ciudad de río de janeiro
brevemente les presentamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana en
nuestro continente brevemente les cuento
que el gobierno de colombia indicó que
exigirá vacunación completa o una prueba
de pcr negativa para todos los turistas
que deseen ingresar al país la medida
busca ayudar a mitigar el impacto de la
pandemia y también a evitar que casos de
la variante omicron ingresen a ese país
colombiano ha registrado casos hasta el
momento de esa variante y brevemente
también descuento que la ope se
determinó que para considerar vacunación
completa con la vacuna de sinovac que es
desarrollada en china a las personas
mayores de 60 años deberán ser
inoculadas con al menos 3 dosis de lo
contrario no será considerado como un
esquema completo de vacunación y la ema
que es la autoridad sanitaria de la
unión europea anunció que la vacuna
sputnik en sus dos versiones la versión
b y la versión l puede ser usada para
ser inoculada en europa en esquema
completo de vacunación o como un
refuerzo de otras vacunas disponibles en
la unión europea esto pone fin al
arresto es que el bloque comunitario le
había impuesto a esta vacuna que es
desarrollada en rusia
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con kobe 19 con
estas pandemias destacadas también en
redes preocupa a la ms que los países
ricos
acaparen las vacunas de kobe 19 el
organismo teme que ante la incertidumbre
y la preocupación que ha generado la
aparición de la variante omicron en el
mundo los países más desarrollados
aceleren el acopio de vacunas y afecten
el suministro global lo que dificultará
también poder poner fin a la pandemia
ips haití y cinco países más no
cumplirán la meta de vacunación la
organización continental indicó que
junto con este país también guatemala
jamaica san vicente y las granadinas
santa lucia y grenada no llegarán a la
meta del 40 por ciento de sus habitantes
inmunizados para el 2021 como lo pidió
la ms
y es todo en este resumen semanal de
kobe 19 la semana en américa nos
volvemos a encontrar a partir de
mediados del mes de enero después de un
receso por las fiestas de fin de año
sigan cuidando sea la emergencia
persiste y nos vemos aquí en france 24
hasta entonces
[Música]